everybody is Charlie this is going to be
my flash episode 15 video careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet things got crazy so bad so I'll try
to explain what's going on but you kind
of see how this is moving the episode
next week is into the speedforce
so now we have the reason for why Barry
needs to travel in there but you kind of
see how characters learn information
where most of us probably suspected that
avatar was stuck in the Speed Force way
a long time ago so there's a new round
of the flash ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video so a whole bunch
of comic book stuff I'll try to explain
the concepts and the speedforce avatar
in the comics as we go along so number
10 the team is training Wally to save
iris and it's kind of morbid because
they're trying to replicate the exact
scene of irises debt so Barry's
pretending to be savat are killing iris
who's being played by Jesse quick and
even other planes it's really hopeful
music and they're all kind of really
excited because while he's actually
doing really good is it it's just
completely nuts you have to remember
that Wally is still kid flash he's
really still a kid inside and nowhere
else do you see that then when he sees
his mother later in the episode like he
really just needs someone to balance him
out the way his mother could but she's
not around anymore so he's completely
spinning out of control as number 9 he
starts to hallucinate savat are so no
big deal we get an answer for what
happened last week he didn't tell
anybody about it so I guess he just went
and got big belly burger then came back
and finished that movie with Jesse quick
can you just imagine the weird behavior
he tried to explain away when he came
back that night but they did this weird
thing in the episode with the way they
presented Savitt are as Wally's
hallucination
so nobody else could see him even Barry
couldn't see him when he was getting
knocked around so it seems like he did
have a connection with Wally he really
was knocking him around it wasn't just
Wally imagining in that it has something
to do with the ways Wally got his powers
from the Philosopher's Stone through
Savitt are I am the one that gave you
these powers so I guess that gave them
some extra level of connection that
someone like Barry does not have with
Savitt are even those avatars completely
obsessed with them you're the one that
put me in here Barry Allen your future
self so number 8 Barry speaks to him for
the first time and they start to tease
the idea of the prison that he's trapped
in an endless void of time and energy so
it takes them a while to get there but
they eventually figure out that it is
the speed force that he's stuck in even
those avatar himself didn't say that but
here's the thing this is really cool
because this first encounter they have
what's avatar in the episode he dumps
all this information on them from my
perspective you're the big bat you're
selfish you're cruel so that means that
Barry does something crazy he says that
they'll meet relatively shortly he could
be talking about the end of the episode
when Savitt are finally manifests in the
real world but he also makes it sound
like Barry was there when he became a
speedster but the waste avatar was
talking about himself the way he got
powers was really weird because
technically by jay garrick's explanation
he's the first speedster to be granted
speed but that would make him way older
than any of these characters and have
been around for a much much longer time
but he calls himself the future so it
doesn't make a lot of sense like the
timeline doesn't completely make sense
so maybe they change their minds and
stuff let's wait for some more
information and in the comics avatar was
just a regular Cold War pilot but still
became one of the earliest speedsters to
be granted speed but the waste avatar
talks about Barry makes it sound like
they have a much more intimate
relationship in history like he's not
just somebody from the other side of the
world that got speed became a villain
and Barry took down it seems way more
complicated than that
in by this explanation him being stuck
in the Speed Force they've already hit
that comic book storyline so in the
comics avatar doesn't start out trapped
in the Speed Force he starts out just
like a normal person who has speed who
winds up getting stuck in there by Wally
West who defeats him after he tries to
take down his entire team he tries to
steal the Speed Force from everyone
Wally ultimately defeats him but then
later after Barry Allen had come back
during flash rebirth savitur escapes the
Speed Force and then completely
disintegrates as part of a different
storyline so they're mixing and matching
some Barry Allen Wally West era stuff
but eventually they learn number 6 the
method of sabotage return is that the
Philosopher's Stone isn't completely
gone and that sort of queues up the
other acolytes he still has followers
that are on the loose worshiping some
creepy statue of
in the park and it all seems like a
setup thats avatar has engineered so
that they'll get the box they'll find
the stone and then the stone will be
thrown into the Speed Force so even
those avatar was manipulating them at
every step through this episode like
manipulating things so that wall-e would
steal the stone and throw it into the
Speed Force he's been doing it ever
since
flashpoint started so number 5 wall-e
biting into the future so that he can
see irises deaths also big WTF sort of
sets off a couple other plot lines like
Barry and iris breaking off their
engagement and we learned why Wally
isn't there in that moment because the
Barry is training in to save iris why
wouldn't he be there in the future
vision well now we know because he's
stuck in the Speed Force and how crazy
was it the Cisco was able to turn on a
dime and just vibe them right there like
here you go it's almost like turning a
TV to a different station like oh let's
turn to the station where iris gets
skewered by avatar let's check that out
again it'll be no big deal number four
we learn more of the prophecy Caitlin is
the ones that betrayed the team so it
seems like things are playing out the
way avatar said they would even though
I'm expecting a couple twists down the
road because she kept a piece of stone
to try and get rid of her powers but
can't figured out in while it shatters
her relationship with Julianne it also
kind of does the same thing for everyone
else in the episode like Barry and iris
are freaking out Jessie and Wally are
freaking out so it's almost like all the
relationships in the episode whether
they're friends or their girlfriend
boyfriend
are all just completely blowing apart at
the seams we got to talk about Caitlin
though how crazy off the rails do you
think that she's gone she is so positive
that she is going to go full-blown
killer froth and he's are hurt or kill
her friends so even though you
understand why she kept that peace why
she's so desperate it's still a huge WTF
twist so she'll be living with that
regret for the rest of the season but
I'll be interested to see how the show
tries to redeem her if it's able to do
so like even if she's eventually going
to become killer frost no matter what if
she'll be able to use her powers for
good I think it's a crazy assumption
that just because she becomes killer
frost and gets those powers she can't
use them in a good way
continuing the crazy train number 3
Wally goes completely off the rails
hallucinating
mother as Sabbat our and he goes from
kind of sweet and crazy like oh my god
Jesse quick definitely can't see her
you're scaring me Wally
- really creepy where they have her
start to taunt Wally so what's happening
here is this avatar is goading him to
get him to throw the piece into the
Speed Force that's why he's doing this
he's not just doing this to get Wally to
crap his pants he's manipulating him so
that he can get sucked into the Speed
Force and replace avatar but number two
now the relationship blowing a part of
the scenes iris breaks off the
engagement with Barry predictably
because of what happened in the episode
but if you felt like their engagement
was really quick like I know they get
married in the comics eventually that
leads to Bart Allen their grandson so
all good things come from them getting
married eventually but they're so young
so my barometer on their whole
relationship is really based on
Smallville experience like you know
they'll end up together Lois and Clark
they belong together totally get it but
it just push it off into the future you
don't have to rush to that finish line
right away but we learned the whole
reason it's just because Barry was
trying to change the future they're not
married in the future so if they get
married maybe that's one more thing that
will help save iris witches Iris
explains is a completely terrible reason
to get married so they're still together
like they didn't break up
it just is they're not going to be
getting married anytime soon but you
guys can let me know like do you think
they're going to push that off to like
the final season of the show because it
would be crazy for them to get married
this soon we're only in season three
maybe like season seven or eight or
whatever the final season of the show is
my number one this is so great so the
final 15 minutes of the episode which is
one crazy thing leading to another
domino knocking down to this giant
explosion of WTF so wally takes the
stone turns his communicator off in
plays in this avatars hand not knowing
that throwing the stone into the Speed
Force is giving savitur what he wants so
this is all predicated on the idea that
they didn't know where exactly the
avatar was they still don't really
understand how the Speed Force works
Barry knows he was stuck in there there
are beings that exist that he was able
to talk to but that's basically it so
there's a lot of Speed Force lore from
the comics that they just haven't got to
on the show yet they'll get to of
eventually this season in obviously in
future seasons there are so many things
about the speedforce that they change
even in the brand new rebirth comics
that they could do later on that it's
going to be really cool so is we get the
stuff I'll try to explain it whenever
they do big concepts but the whole thing
here is is that Wally gets sucked in and
it's almost exactly like when Barry got
sucked into the Speed Force who sort of
disintegrates in his costume is left in
tatters it's kind of a reverse homage to
crisis on Infinite Earths and this panel
here with Wally West holding Barry
Allen's costume after he got sucked into
the Speed Force so it all comes back
around to the comics but you guys can
let me know what do you think is going
on with savatage they got a piece of his
armor so they'll use it to learn more
about him but Barry wasn't able to rip
his mask off so they haven't revealed
who he is exactly they haven't had their
arrow moment where they've revealed the
big bad but I feel like this was a great
episode there were a couple moments
where it lagged a little bit but the
final 15 minutes which is so solid in
that fight between him and Barry I feel
like those types of CG scenes always
work a lot better it feels like they
spend a lot more time making that that
much crazier so the thing is though is
that even though avatar supposed to be
the god of speed Barry was able to get a
couple really good punches in meaning
that there is a chance for him to fight
them but first he has to find out what's
going on with Wally and then we have to
learn what the will of the Speed Force
is why it's allowing all of this to
happen because we have the time rates
there are things that the Speed Force
itself can do to act against things that
it thinks aren't supposed to exist so
remember Barry Allen's very important
for the evolution of Savitt are there's
a lot they haven't explained yet so
let's try and figure this out in the
comments but what's going to happen next
is I have a new game of Thrones video
that reveals a new character so I'll
post a video for that there might be a
new Wonder Woman trailer tomorrow they
said it's going to happen sometimes this
week probably because King Khan is
dropping so whenever that happens I will
totally do a video for it but
congratulations to this week's flash
ring giveaway winner Jeremy hall please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details so I will see you guys when I
post that Game of Thrones video in the
morning while you wait for that you can
click here for brand new game of Thrones
you can click here for that musical
crossover episode trailer thank you so
much for watching let's I thought I'll
see you guys
the next video
you